Oliver burkman has this other idea about
choose in advance what you're going to
suck at for a period of time you're
going to work on your business and
you're going to grow your net worth or
you're going to try and double the
revenue of your business or you're going
to try and get a raise or get a
promotion or do whatever that period of
life just as important as what are you
going to do is what you prepared to
sacrifice for it or if you need to stay
late in the office three nights a week
for the next 6 months so that your boss
sees the work that you're doing or so
that you get more sales in your
trading's probably going to take a hit
and when you start to see your condition
or your Fitness depreciate over time if
you're a type a go-getter you can feel
uncomfortable and say that shouldn't be
happening and then you take your eye off
the ball of the thing that was supposed
to be your thing for the next six months
and then go I'll only stay late in the
office one night a week and I'll fit
training I'll slot training in two more
nights that wasn't the plan the plan was
put everything into this one thing level
myself up and then play catch up with
everything else to bring myself back up
to Baseline choose in advance what you
want to suck at is like a really really
good tactic that thing that sucks at the
moment it's not going to suck later on
precisely like you can easily switch out
suck